true story last night recorded a review
for this movie and the audio was
because the onboard audio I use a zoom
h4n hooked into a microphone that rests
right here well anyhow the onboard mic
was selected for some weird stupid
reason I don't know a ghost selected it
ironically for this review but the point
is the audio was I was like I I
can't oh the battery on my camera is
dying
I'm gonna play some Mortal Kombat one
I'm going to bed I'll deal with this
tomorrow so it's the next day is my
second go around recording a review for
this movie if this review sucks rest
assured my first go around was probably
better all right here we go
so a haunting in Venice is the third go
around for Kenneth Branagh playing the
character Hercule Hercule pero I'm not
going to struggle to pronounce it I'm
just going to mispronounce it for your
amusement anyhow let's start go around
playing the character also was third go
around directing a film starring the
character which he plays and I gotta say
the other two movies murder on the
Orient Express death on the Nile they're
fine but I always felt like the end
reveal of the investigation is the point
it's kind of a trap that a lot of these
murder mystery movies fall into I can't
help but see the end reveal of the
murder mystery as the more important
part of the point the the destination
more important than the journey so to
speak is it due to the directing or just
how I Annex the information I don't know
a question for the philosopher is
probably that second one but it's just
it's how I am I guess however murder in
Venice I thought had an incredible Hook
that the other two were lacking because
it's not a murder mystery it doesn't
start out that way anyway it becomes a
murder mystery but the initial point of
him going to this place using his
particular set of skills is to debunk a
supernatural claim of mysticism and
haunting that's just fascinating to me
also if you've never gone down the
rabbit hole of seeing people debunk
Mystics and otherwise scammers you were
letting the best in life pass you by
free entertainment on YouTube folks is
there for you to enjoy have fun but in a
world where what the eyes see and the
ears hear the Mind believes having a
very grounded and logical character like
him come face to face with things that
are seemingly Supernatural it was just
more it gripped me I wasn't fixated on
who is the murderer that's the important
point I was more enjoying the ride as I
experienced it the ride of the main
character's logical brain going that
can't be Supernatural but the Primal
part of the wiring of his brain still
being there being like yeah fight or
flight obviously it is because we all
have that we come from a long line of
very smart ancestors who were like the
shadows and darkness that that's where
predators are I'm gonna stay next to the
campfire in the cave thank you we don't
necessarily need to logically think like
that per se in this this day and age but
the wiring is still there it always
cracks me up we all know that very
logical person who's like I'm a staunch
atheist ghosts do not exist sweet
there's a haunted hotel downtown you
want to stay a weekend in a room no
right because fear fight or flight it
just overrides logic and it was really
entertaining seeing famed investigator
hair Q Perot still fall into the same
we fall into there are also some
fun moments of cinematography camera
working camera play to hammer home those
moments those really close up
claustrophobic isolating shots I mean
it's not a psychological Deep dive kind
of film or anything but I will say the
hook of its premise was a proper sequel
it took the character in new directions
for us also I like the fact that his
character does show growth it doesn't
feel like the character from the
previous films is just kind of copied
and pasted into here like years haven't
gone by because the growth never stops
my friends the growth stops when you die
this film understands that his
reputation precedes him at this point
people line up outside his door to
Ambush him when he leaves for the day
you know whoa please investigate this or
that he just has to tell these people no
I felt the toll that his life and job is
taken on his soul it felt real it felt
lived it's not like they just made him
boring out of the blue and called it
growth because they don't know how to
write a life that feels lived also
cherry on top no other way to say it the
movie is a perfect run time clocks in at
about an hour and a half internet says
it's an hour 40 minutes I feel like
that's with end credit so we'll go ahead
and call it around an hour and a half I
know I about run times a lot on
here it's not that a long movie by
nature is going to annoy me a long movie
annoys me if it's too long without
purpose just like a movie that feels too
short and rushed also annoys me the
perfect run time for a film is a perfect
run time for a film if it's four hours
so be it if it's 90 minutes so be it the
run time of a haunting in Venice I felt
was perfect for a hunting in Venice in
the end I enjoyed this one of the
Kenneth Brana directed we'll call it a
Trilogy now of hair cool this is my
favorite of the three and I had myself a
good time with this one no alcohol
required right it's about Friday evening
at this point hopefully you all still
give a how was the wrong button on
that thing selected I don't know
ghosts I tell ya ghosts need to get hair
cute parole in here and be like how is
how is that selected not that maybe it's
because I grip it like that
all right so a haunting in Venice
have you seen it what did you think
about it or it's a Trilogy now so how do
you rank him in order best to worst
worst to best however you want to do it
you can do a second third first second
first third first second third third
second first in which case ranking him
would mean absolutely nothing at that
point whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
foreign